I always have been a scientist my
earliest recollections are the same sort
of interest in things and how things
work and want to take things apart and
put them together again I wanted to be
an inventor where I as a child probably
six years old seven years old something
like reading about a comic strip about
this person who was an inventor and I
thought I I would like to be an inventor
particularly my uncle for example I
think he was it was an example both as a
human being as well as a scientist and
he was a very gifted scientist and my
wife and I often talk about it about our
various people who will have worked or
are working with us and whether they
have what we call the fire and they're
the ones who come back at the weekend
and they're always there and they're
always asking the question and they
can't bear not to know the answers many
mainly students at the undergraduate
level they come in and they say what do
we need to know and I said well you need
to understand the subject I think what
we're looking for is passion I mean I
think you have to have some you have to
have abilities but I think if you if you
don't have the passion or the abilities
don't make any difference there's no
substitute for working hard I don't care
how gifted the person is those who don't
work hard don't do well next morning you
come and you see your result and oh it's
not what you wanted but it's exciting it
is and now I know what I have to do to
make it okay in a sense I view my life
assume that we're always playing and
we're given out but somebody else pays
for it and we're given the opportunities
so we have a bunch of puzzles and we're
putting them together in different ways
and then all of a sudden you see the
picture the thing which gives you
pleasure is that you can think about and
say I know my event wrong at least I've
got an idea why it may have gone wrong I
can try it
like this I don't allow radios in my
love what I say to people is you should
be thinking about what you're doing all
the time not with part of your brain and
I do encourage the to have a radio on in
the animal house when you walk into the
room they're quite happy and relaxed yes
they think I'm ready for the main teach
our students a great respect for the
animals that they work with it's a
privilege to be able to work with
animals and you have to regard them as
being precious and not to be wasted or
trivialize so I think there will that
you know until proven otherwise we are
very similar to Mice and mice are very
similar to us in a human population you
know only as an association listen this
genetic change is associated with let's
say high blood pressure but in the mouse
you can do an experiment to show that
this and this difference causes a change
in pressure I think there is an enormous
intellectual exercise for us in
understanding the complexities and the
of the biological world in which we live
we are part of the biological world but
we're not all of the biological world
you